it was one of those rare times
when you
read a script and you immediately say
yes
you've got something you want to
ask me
it was a very violent film for sure a
gangster story an all-star cast and
those boston accents you have different
accents
you did didn't you
the departed had it all and the academy
agreed a lot of awards coming marty's
with in the remake of the hong kong
crime thriller infernal affairs martin
scorsese was in his element
we decided beginning so let's make a
real old-fashioned gangster picture and
then somehow a twist and turn and became
something else
and i said well nobody will ever i said
look as long as some people enjoy it and
audiences did enjoy it in 2007 the
departed napped five oscar nominations
for adapted screenplay editing actor in
a supporting role directing and motion
picture of the year you know this is my
first time it's it's been a whirlwind
experience speaking at the oscar
luncheon wahlberg joked about his full
circle moment but i was arrested by the
boston police
20 some odd time you know the amazing
thing was when i when i got the call
that i was nominated i was able to call
my parents
and tell them good news that made them
cry for the first time in my life the
nominee was reunited with leonardo
dicaprio the two previously co-starred
in the basketball diaries who's doing
the interview sorry pal
it's your face
you're questioning me man that's the
young actors on set and over a decade
later this playful dynamic showed up on
screen sir yes sir i have an idea oh
whoa let's say you have no idea leave it
at that okay
no idea
zip none
it really bothered leo and matt a lot
when we were doing those scenes and i
was getting in their face and they
couldn't do anything about it i i
thoroughly enjoyed that on show night
the departed won four out of its five
categories
wahlberg lost to little miss sunshine
star alan arkin but he loved celebrating
marty's big night you know he's long
overdue
uh you know i couldn't believe
with his resume that he hadn't had a
whole trophy case full of oscars
so i'm just ecstatic for him yep 30
years after taxi driver over 15 years
after goodfellas and many classics in
between scorsese finally won an academy
award
and the oscar goes to
martin scorsese
speaking backstage scorsese got
sentimental about his presenters who
were long time friends and iconic
directors themselves francis coppola and
george and george lucas and steven
spielberg they've influenced me and when
i saw
that smile on his face steven's face i
said oh you know
something's up and to see the three of
them walk out and give me a look before
they open the envelope i was very
i was very surprised
[Music]
you